do whatever you do best I mean do
whatever you're doing the best you can
knowing there's the bigger horizon
anything you put your name on needs to
be good needs to be the best of what you
can do with that time and energy the
only thing that you're responsible for
is your best like you can't do better
than your best rise and shine it's an
espresso time what's up believe nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message always
do your best over to you Dean grazie Oh
see I literally flew to Arizona to meet
a media buyer and I said I have no idea
what I'm doing and I just kept pushing
in and one of those things that I think
during the evolution of growing from
wherever you are to where you want to go
is do whatever you do best I mean do
whatever you're doing the best you can
knowing there's the bigger horizon so I
literally was working during the day on
cars I was a paint cars I've been doing
a collision repair at night I'd go work
on my apartments and I was a plumber and
and and hung sheetrock and I'd work till
midnight on houses and I was tired but I
had a dream I knew I wanted to help
people do better so it made what I was
doing okay because I knew there was more
so the big problem I see is people want
more and they hate what they're doing so
that it there they're in a they're in a
state of mind where god I just when I'm
done with this crap and someday I'll
reach my dreams and if you can flop that
to go no this is the gateway to my
dreams I don't care that I'm serving
coffee or I'm painting cars or I'm a
teacher right now or I'm on my sister's
couch like this is what I have to do and
I have to do it the best become a master
just become a master at that because and
that's the income and the security and
the mindset that fuels the next level
it's not this is miserable I hate it I
feel the next level and now I'm amazing
it's like you need to master that
yeah the process yeah here
something I want you to try on tell
yourself this whatever I do
wherever I go the people I come in
contact with and the projects I work on
will be better because I was there again
whatever I do wherever I go the people I
come into contact with and the projects
I work on will be better because I was
there here's the thing that holds a lot
of wannabe entrepreneurs especially back
you don't like your life you don't like
your job you don't like your
circumstances you want to break through
and you're not spending enough time on
your business and where you want to go
but you're bringing so much negative
energy to the work that you're currently
doing you're looking at the tasks you do
as a go hard to go and do this you're
putting out so much negative energy
there's no way somebody's gonna
recognize your talent and give you an
opportunity it's crazy how many
opportunities will come to you when you
just bring the best of yourself into
every situation that you're going to so
let me tell you the story about Ivan
Ivan is a guy behind my YouTube channel
he's doing all the research for these
videos putting together all the clips
bringing them to me brainstorming new
topics for the channel a lot of the love
and effort and hard work that goes
behind these videos is thanks to Ivan
when I first hired Ivan I wasn't looking
for a researcher I was looking for
someone to do the comments on my channel
my channel was just exploding they had
lots of people now commenting on my
channel it was getting beyond the point
where I could person respond everybody
and if I did that then I spend no time
actually building my channel and so I
needed some help and so I hired Ivan I
found him online and he'd started doing
a great job
now comments wasn't what he ultimately
wanted to be doing
he started off going to law school and
didn't want to go off and be a lawyer
and he loved the mission that I was on
and said yes I'll join you and be
involved in managing your community but
it wasn't ultimately what he wanted to
do that being said
Ivan poured his heart and soul and
energy and love into providing an
amazing experience for everybody who was
coming up even though it wasn't
ultimately where he wanted to go he was
still porting in crazy amounts of love
and effort to making it the best
possible experience because if Ivan was
a part of it he wanted to be good
anything you put your name on needs to
be good needs to be the best of what you
can do with that time and energy
if you walk your unconscious saying I'm
better than this
I should be doing more and then you mail
in your job I think you're actually
teaching yourself negative self respect
I don't think you ever get to the place
where you want to be it doesn't mean
that you stay in a job that you hate
forever I think it's great to have
standards I think it's great to have a
mission it's great to have a vision it's
great didn't want something better for
yourself but if all you're bringing is
negative energy to your workplace every
day you're gonna lose you're never gonna
get to that next spot so Ivan was doing
the comments he didn't ultimately want
to do that but he was doing a great job
doing it and so now me look at me I'm
I'm I'm his boss I'm trying to figure
out I want my team to win I have this
need right now for the comments but I
love what Ivan's doing I love Ivan's
vibe I love Ivan's personality I love
how dedicated Ivan is to doing something
that he is okay with doing but he knows
there's something more that he wants I'm
now fighting for Ivan right I'm fighting
for Ivan to find something else for him
to do because that's not his ultimate
role
now if Ivan was just merely then not
doing a great job being late you know
I'm not being disrespectful to you guys
in the comments but just doing an okay
job because he didn't like it as much
am I gonna fight for Ivan and do
something better heck no but because he
was pouring so much love and energy
it made me guilty maybe what I love to
try to help Ivan and so we transitioned
him out of that role into the role of
what he's doing right now which is
finding all the research for all the
videos and he loves that role so much
better
but if Ivan didn't bring the best of
himself to the role that he was hired
for he wouldn't be here and be off still
doing something else probably let go of
the job that I hired him for and just
continue to be upset and angry and
blaming other people that's what the
trap that most people fall into
you're bringing so much negative energy
to the work that you're doing that
nobody will recognize your talent and
then you go home and you complain about
the world and how broken it is and how
unfair it is you need to bring more
positive energy to the work that you are
doing constantly people will see that
and then want to work with you and it
often happens in really strange and
weird wonderful ways I look at
relationships as an example one of the
best ways to get into a relationship is
to do hobbies and activities that you
love doing at my
Ronald and salsa so many people have
found relationships why because you're
doing something that you are interested
in doing you're coming to learn how to
dance because it's an interest of yours
to come to learn how to dance and while
you're doing that you're having fun and
you're smiling and you're excited and
you're putting out a great positive
energy and hey there's somebody who you
partner up with who also had that same
positive vibe and energy and is outgoing
and we get people who are coming from
their work who hate their life who hate
their job and we make them have a
positive energy and done now all of a
sudden they're creating relationship
with other people when you're doing
things that you're bringing a positive
energy to you don't have to wait for
some outside force to make that happen
for you like we might do a Toronto dance
salsa you can do it for yourself and the
way to do it is to have self respect and
pride into everything that you touch
everything that you touch needs to be to
the best of your abilities to the best
of your capabilities because you know
that you touched it it's gonna do well
even if you don't like that thing and in
the longer term and in your bigger
roadmap you can have a plan for yourself
of where you want to get to and the path
to getting there is doing these things
really really really well while you're
doing this crazy thing amazingly well
people will see that and say who is this
person I want to hire that person I want
to work with that person I want to learn
more about what they're doing that's how
you get to the next step I go even so
crazy I don't see this too often because
it comes across as very egotistical but
I'm in Toronto I live in Toronto I want
Toronto to be the greatest city in the
world because I'm there I'm at Yonge and
Sheppard is the intersection where our
own events all say is where I live I
want young and Sheppard to be the
greatest intersection in Toronto because
I'm there I want the people that I touch
I want the projects that I work on to
all be better because I had a hand in it
because I'm there I'm in Columbus now I
want Columbus I'm on my tour I want
Columbus to be better because I'm here I
want to leave a mark I want to have an
impact whatever that is even when I
leave this Airbnb I will make the bed I
will clean up the air B&B I want this
place to be better because I was here
from a place of service
if you constantly leave the projects and
the people that you're working with from
a place of service said I want this to
be better because I was here so many
opportunities will come and find you
because most people put out a negative
energy and what do you want to do around
they go to people want to avoid them but
if you're the one rare person who's
bringing positivity to everything that
you're doing people will want to scoop
you up people will find ways to work
with you people will fight to bring you
in to pay you more to be your business
partner to invest in you you just have
to learn to put out more positive energy
and take pride in every single piece of
work that you're doing because you spent
time on it period now I've got a really
special bonus clip that I think you're
going to enjoy but before that question
of the day I want to know where do you
need to bring more positive energy in
your life or business leave your answer
in the comments below
you just got to understand the only
thing that you're responsible for is
your best like you can't do better than
your best you just do your best and if
you try to obsess too much you're not
doing your best you're gonna be
paralyzed right so you have to get as
much information as you can make the
most educated choice make sure that
you're not choosing based on ego or
emotion or you know greed or these other
forces that delude you and prevent you
from thinking clearly but if you do your
best and you fail like what are you
gonna do beat yourself up for that like
that doesn't make any sense if you're
doing your best if you're really laying
it out there there's nothing nothing
more you can do and and that's I think
that that's really the key is just to
constantly rest and rely on that fact
that I'm just I'm doing my best and
there's nothing nothing more than that
so I was going in for my big interview
with justice O'Connor and I was very
nervous and fortunately I happen to have
a friend who had gotten there the year
before and was clerking for the chief
justice and so he had lunch with me
before to sort of you know be a friendly
face and so I said to him I was like the
thing is Jim do you ever worry whether
you're good enough to do the job like I
worry like can I really handle it and he
looked at me and he said Gretchen she's
a justice on the Supreme Court she's
hired dozens of clerks it's her problem
to figure out if you are good enough to
do the job you have to focus on trying
to get the job I found that enormous ly
comforting and now often when I'm
thinking like oh I don't know am I good
enough am I gonna be able to pull this
off I think to myself you know what it's
for other people to decide whether I'm
good enough it's my job to worry about
whether I'm just doing my best and if
you want more Dean grazioso you check
out the top ten rules video made on him
the link that's right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
and I want to tell you passion and from
the heart always always wins over over
prepared and thinking from the head